I'm so excited because we're gonna do
hoe cakes today which I'm a huge fan of
oh same I love corn I love corn so much
corn I want I find ways to put corn in
whatever I can so it's such an important
thing it actually is indigenous to North
America which is so great about it
really yeah yeah Native Americans
actually there's a really funny story
about the origin of like a Johnny cake
or a hoe cake which is what we're making
yeah so like food historians are kind of
like all over the place about what exact
tribe created this like thing we know is
a Johnny cake but it was probably the
Shawnee Indians and the Shawnee Native
Americans and basically the English
settlers came in and they are basically
mispronouncing it so it's supposed to be
called a Shawnee cake but they heard
Johnny cake so that's where that term
comes from and how did no cake come out
of that so A whole cake was so enslaved
folks when they were brought here 400
years ago they only had access to
cornmeal water salt they didn't have
heating elements so they would actually
have to make these which is why they're
the shape on the bottom of a hoe of a
farming tool because that's all they had
access to so they would Heat their
farming tools and they would make their
little hoe cakes and that's why they're
so small later on in the 18th and 19th
century what we now know today is a
griddle they called a hoe so now stood
the hoe is the hoe literally aren't
these origin stories amazing
okay let's do it well I'm excited teach
me so just whisk those up yep whisk them
up yep yep yep yep and as you whisk I'm
gonna do this oh my god oh I'm sorry
like Martha Stewart gave me like so much
Guff about my whisking game so now I'm
like no oh Martha tell Martha to calm
down Martha does love to I love you
Martha but
you know okay I just told Martha Stewart
to calm down on TV she's go ahead I love
it no she's not but that's what I love
about her she's so tough she's so
intense I know like she's scared it's
been the best way ever it's like I'm
scared and turned on I'm so confused I
saw her scold Christina toasty one time
yeah no she does it was intense I kind
of weird people sickly like it though so
like you what you wanted to do you want
to pour that in as you're whisking so
you create emulsification so this is
exactly emulsify so then you're gonna
take that you see how we also have this
bowl with the poor I love a spout don't
you love it right into the center see
now I'm gonna whisk too okay whisk keep
whisking yes I'm Gonna Keep whisking and
you're gonna pour once you get this all
Incorporated it's actually really good
to let your batters rest for at least 30
minutes oh really yeah it's really good
to let those glutens kind of relax let
it rest so then so then also see how
thick it is it's 20 30 minutes later yes
pretend so we got some oil in the pan
but you see look what look how different
yeah it's much thicker right that's good
that's a good thing yeah yeah
this is really hot I'm working too hot I
don't know let's see let's see maybe
it's not
let's see maybe it's not
I don't want to turn it down too much
because now it's got no heat it's good
it's good oh that looks good yeah right
and so what we're gonna we have over
here is some butter because we're gonna
make a special syrup because why do a
basic one and you can do a special one
you come over here and whisk this so you
whisk this so we have honey and maple
syrup because honey is more for flavor
maple syrup is more for texture okay the
more when you mix sweeteners you get
depth which is really really nice
because people think oh what's a
different tiny Maple they really do
taste different and have completely
different textures how am I doing over
here they're doing so but it's like
perfect but you see how we're doing it
on the stovetop yeah it's so I think I
really think heating yours whatever
you're gonna put on top whether it's
butter heating it beforehand and just
letting it kind of hang out there it's
almost like a glaze you know what I'm
saying I do so we're gonna do this but
see we're already set up over here
through
so like we're already good so like what
I'm gonna do do we have a spoon yeah
let's take a spoon so like what we can
do is we can actually like literally we
can just go like this stop it that's a
slotted spoon do you see
like what is trying to get you a bigger
skin no I'm into the little Sky I like a
little baby spoon do you see me I'm like
come over here here I'm gonna give this
to you like a dog with a bone but it's
so good I'm so and like do you even the
crispiness yeah listen all that also
like in my one can I be like this can I
do yes oh my God and the spice come on
and it's so good this is so good
the outside has this very um nice like
crushed almost like texture but it's not
hard yes it's still soft and then the
inside is really Airy thank you so much
thank you so much
new episodes of counter space
um do you want the star treatment for
half the price in Los Angeles well our
travel guide Vegas starfish is here and
I'm from LA and I saw her suggestions
and I was like yes don't go anywhere
[Music]
foreign